thank you
all good on the mic yeah
all right
today we'll do some information
extraction
um we will chain up some tasks
particularly name density recognition
and relationship extraction
uh
we also mostly have named entity linking
within this pipeline
but that will be too long for this talk
so i just left that out but we will
get onto it theoretically
i'm ahmed uh you can reach me by that
link and also feel free to
join on the coding
uh while getting into the repo there
also want to thank like some colleagues
here they have helped in the content and
the
models that we ran for this
content
also the data sets
all right so this presentation is more
focused on the task
and why we need it how we formulate it
and how we apply it
and
how i want to start on that is
why i think in some cases
so let's say we have three types of
people
and they all have
large amounts of take text data on their
hands
and they want to apply
various
kinds of machine learning techniques
to
process that data into a structured
format
so let's say there's
tony and he's a partner in an investment
fund he's doing a lot of due diligence
and he's checking what are these
companies up to have they been involved
in something bad what events have
happened with them which companies were
they
involved with
and in our case tony is interested in
getting information on gamestop
there's also natasha who's
a researcher working on cancer so she's
trying to skim out these articles on the
internet
by using some smarter techniques rather
than reading them all
there's also kamala trying to
catch up with the competitors on
corporate strategy again
interested in what their competitors are
involved with
now as we work these tasks you can see
you can have a feel that these have some
similarities between them
so all of these people have some kind of
raw text data and they want to obtain
structured information from it
structured information can sound a bit
vague right now we will get into the
details
so our question is solving each of these
individuals problems
and we are assuming we have row text
data again
let's say we have obtained some data
sources on the internet
these also could be internal resources
to be honest
but
then we wouldn't all be familiar with
some sources that i would present here
so i'm just coming up with reddit wall
street journal
and
archive
so after we get our data sources
identified
we are starting to get relevant
documents from them because we don't
want all of we don't want to utilize all
of the archive
repository rather
we won't query relevant articles
so in tony's case it would be gme
and he would
query gme
within wall street journal to get
relevant articles
after we obtain a subset of documents
we are starting to process them
and that is why uh that is starting
via named entity recognition
by entities
we mean
part particular nouns of interest
like names locations
dates organizations
but depending on our use case
let's say we go back to natasha
these could be scientific entities let's
say drugs chemicals
virus types
so we can formulate our entity classes
as
diverse as we like
i like to imagine
entities in a text
like nodes in a graph
say we had different documents
and we started to extract
some notes from each of them
so in document one we have gme as a
company
and
we also extracted another company named
apple
in document two we have another gme
but that is something different
that's graduate medical education
i just put that as a caveat
to see why nel is important named entity
linking we will come up to that later
there is an organization named
university of oxford
you can also see
two
two other sets of companies in document
three and document 4.
next step is
in our pipeline to find the relations
the types of relations
between these nodes
so one case that we could have is having
no relation between them
and that is also a class we formulate
into the architecture of our model
if we take the pair of gme and apple and
i will get into the details of how we do
that
and we classify them as a pair into a
class that class could be no relation
also
that class could be
sued
which means
either jamie sued robin hood or robin
hood
sued gme
you could have different classes to
direct the relation
it could be also acquired again you can
have direction by diversifying the class
now
[Music]
another part that is
kind of like magic here is
now check all these gme nodes please
when i look at them i can see that this
one
and the one in document three and four
are actually the same things in reality
they are the same objects they are the
same entities
in document 2 there is something else
that is written in the same way but is
something different
its graduate medical education rather
than the gamestop company
so when we do named entity linking
we cluster or regroup
these three mansions
terminologically
into one
and we leave the other one out
so now we are starting to have a
meaningful graph
any questions up until now
all right
so in this presentation what we will
cover further is
we already did some of the planning
theoretically
we have solved the problem
we have thought about the data sources
and task formulation
now we will get into
the details of implementation a bit
i try to
give some ideas on acquiring data
and the tasks
and serving the results
they will be really basic
so about acquiring some data
after you identify your sources you
either obtain api access to them
formally or you scrape
or you could have already existing
internal data
resulting from your
internal operational processes
you should parse
the obtained raw data to a common format
because let's say wall street journal's
api and reddit's api will be different
in structure
but if you parse them into a
common format then you can process all
of these
in sync
after that we store it
there are a variety of storing options
and you start the query from where you
store your data
okay
we have our data now we need to process
it
we again have only the raw text but it's
now parsed in a common format we will
process it
add our predictions to our data store
and we will use that
when we are processing the first first
step is to do name named entity
recognition
how this works is you get the raw text
document
here we have a document that i got from
wikipedia
you use an er model and a tokenizer
firstly you apply the tokenizer to
separate your raw documents into tokens
that those are processable units of text
they are mapped to integers
which are then mapped into vectors
and then inside the model there are
vector and matrix calculations
what we basically do is we classify each
token into a class
and then we group the tokens back into
words
to see
say this is a three-word
entity
but we won't group it into
one object
after we
group them back
that's all we have
some popular models to do nr right now
is there is look
there is excel net based models and
work-based based models
look is particularly interesting
if you're
also
into the topic
so we got the notes now right
what we need is the relations after that
so a way to do this as really simple way
is to
represent each entity with a vector
then get a tuple of vectors so
a pair of vectors
and classify that pair
into a class again
then we know what kind of relation
exists between them
to make it simpler
we have a pair of nodes
and we classify each of them
and what do i mean by
the vectors of entities
if you have heard of language models
before
you can tokenize your text and transform
each token into a meaningful vector
which represents the meaning in a
hyper-dimensional space but basically
you can do the same thing for an entity
you can take the average of the
say three
tokens here
or more
or you can apply more complicated
methods to obtain a
vector for your entity
again
some popular ways to do
relationship extraction today is using
loop-based models or roberta-based
models
all right
let's get into some coding
so this is
not totally end-to-end like a tutorial
but it should give an idea on each part
and hopefully
give a sense of the total pipeline
firstly we will get some data
basic scraping
maybe even boring
then
we have the models and we will parse
save the results and show them
i'm sometimes having errors
with sending the requests to reddit
but what i'm doing here is basically i
have a url we could also have a list of
those
and i'm using beautiful soup
to parse scrape it
i think i'm not connected to the
internet now
but i already have the result
say it here
so after this after i send the request
and get the swoop object back
i basically extract the text from each p
tag
and append it into a list that's a basic
thing i can do
and here are some p tags that i have
i just got the first seven
now say i scraped the source what should
i do next
i parse it into a common format
this could include ids this could
include the source id a source url that
i obtained this from
the date i obtained it
also
essentially the content so the text
content between the p tags
say i have implemented various parsers
to parse wall street journal reddit and
bioarchive
content into a common format
after that i i need to store it in a
shared environment
so what i can do is i can use an
elasticsearch python client to open an
index
and post my parsed documents into the
index so i can query it later
here you see my index name
the type of
data that i will post and
the content
say i have applied all this process for
various types of data and now i have a
good bunch of data existing in my data
store
what i then need to do is
querying my existing
store
to get some documents to get into get
them into the models
here i'm again calling the python
elasticsearch client
and i'm sending a query
with a particular date range
this time on elon musk let's say we are
doing an analysis on elon musk and we're
interested in where he goes where he did
go
recently
and my query is basically a string named
elon musk
after i get some articles about this
let's show them to you
so here are
under dash separated documents
so this document
mentions about some employees getting
sacked
this is about twitter affairs
with elon musk but i don't want to read
all of these rather i want to apply my
models and extract the information
in the notebook i didn't
go into the details of applying the
models
if you have been to the previous talk or
various other talks
there are open source solutions that you
can do this with
so if you use transformers
you can get a
ner model tokenizer
ner model itself put them into a
pipeline
apply the pipeline to the article that
you have
to obtain the entities that we extracted
for relationship extraction
i didn't yet see a pipeline type
implemented
so actually that's a good
i think
opportunity to do some contribution
maybe
or maybe i'm wrong and there is a
pipeline existing
again if we would have a pipeline we
would get
a tokenizer for the loop model
then the loop model itself put it into
the pipeline and get our predictions
to remind of it again
we are getting entities entity objects
say a list of dictionaries from the ner
model already
then we need to pair those
and pair
maybe specific type of entities
so if i'm interested in the visited
relation
maybe i shouldn't
pair per
person entities with personal entities
because a person visiting another person
might not make sense in my use case so
applying that kind of rule based magic
logic
is also useful
after i get my edges
of the graph
by applying relationship extraction
i have some data on my hand
now let's load that
let's print it and also let's see a
graph of it
so i have just loaded a json dataset
that has
these edges and notes
within
for each document
in this dataset
each article
i have objects called visits
these can be none
as you remember
my relation
can be of non-type
in that case i'm just not getting those
also
there's this problem where i have
many mentions of the same notes
and also many duplicate relations
so i just get a set
so i have 42
visiting
relations now
here i'm also applying some metadata so
i was interested in
getting the article titles so which
events was this relation
appearing in
i've also added that
basically by linking my notes
to the article title
after i get all all of my notes
i also append another note
which is a long mask
here's how it looks
i'm also trying to parse it into a
common format
for me to visualize it in a dash app
so horsetailwind farms is a location
which elon musk
apparently visited
or our model things that he visited it
you can ignore this part
it's just for visualization purposes
here's how my edges look
so from elon musk
there's an edge to the miami entity
and
this relation was found in the article
named
sai participated in bitcoin 2021 blah
blah
similarly i have other data points
so what i did right now
is i obtained
this state
what i didn't do is apply any out
because i already have
only elon musk as a
source entity
and
i also applied a set operation to
deduplicate the locations
but normally if i would have multiple
people that i'm interested in analyzing
i would need to do some any especially
if they have common names between
so let's dump this
data structure that we have
and see it in a dash app
a very basic way to set it up is
i implement dash
i import dash
then i read the json i just
dumped
i create a dash app
with some html elements
then
i have each relation each edge
and each node
here in the elements argument
let's run this
let's make the surprise
and not show this one
all right
you can customize your graphs further
but
here's essentially what we have
there's elon musk and we have a bunch of
locations
where graph representations become more
valuable is
when we have
more
roots
nodes
and maybe those root nodes can also have
relations between them
so if people would have also relations
between them and if i would have
multiple people
just like elon musk
then a graph representation
maybe would be more valuable than
just printing these
so as a summary
we were interested in doing information
extraction on raw text
we can imagine this as obtaining
relational database content
just by applying machine learning models
rather than doing manual labor
and we have tried to understand the
problems the use cases that could result
in this
after that we formulated our task in
three components
and
we have seen some implementation in
python
to
apply each of those
any questions
thank you alex
[Applause]
questions for abbott over here
there we are
hi thanks for the talk
i had
a couple of questions one
related i think to
um
to the training of the of the of the
data right of the name of the ner
extraction itself right so in this case
of course you we're just taking kind of
an off-the-shelf
model but
probably for most problems with me have
to do some transfer learning i guess
right to train our customer yes
um okay and and then the second question
was more related to the
well in this case you were saying okay
i'm interested in for example the
an edge labeled uh visited for example
right so is
in this formulation of the task
do um
are you using
a transformer that has been trained on a
question and answer task
so that you can parse the full text and
kind of ask
uh ask
has this person visited in kind of and
that's how you kind of get your
classification or how do you actually
train that a great question actually um
we can formulate it in various ways so
how i mentioned it here was taking a
pair of vectors
let's get into it again
so
the mask entity
is represented by a vector
and pretoria entity is also represented
by another vector
we are feeding these
simultaneously to a model
and the model is applying some attention
calculation together with the context
fed
to classify those
into a class so this is a classifier our
relationship extraction model
and what we do is we feed it
each pair
and basically get the classes
to get the edges but as you stated
it is possible to formulate this problem
as a question answering model
and it is actually something we do
internally in our company
so what we do is
we have
the node
fed into a template sentence
say
what is x
what has x visited
today
and you feed ex with various types of
people
and for the relation for each type of
relation you have a different sentence
template
so i just
structured that sentence so the question
answering model would give an answer on
the location
but you can have different templates and
when you create training data based on
those templates it starts to work and
that's another way to formulate
relationship extraction
thank you on the first question though
i think you have asked how we train
these models
and do we apply transfer learning
the particular process in that is
so let's say i have an er model
this would include a
pre-trained language model within it
just to get the token
embeddings
after that it would be trained further
on
maybe a
common data set
but what i do later is
i could actually annotate some examples
by my myself
and train it further on a couple of
hundreds of examples
to
actually make the
model capable in my task formulation and
my use case
so that's particularly how we approach
shawndos
lovely any other questions for amit
lovely then we'll call it there then
thank you very much
[Applause]